hi so I'm Chicago sir and I'm the
director of the Symons Institute the
theory of computing and UC Berkeley and
this summer at the Science Institute
we've been experimenting with the new
format of summer activities we are
running summer clusters which are
focused research efforts on various
topics in computer science and in the
theory of computer science and by focus
research efforts I mean we invite a
smaller group than a large scale program
to come to the Simons Institute and to
study problems of interest and of
importance in a sustained and focused
manner for a period of three two weeks
to six to eight weeks in the summer time
and we were very fortunate to run two of
these classes this summer one of them
was a cluster of quantum computation and
one of them was a mini cluster a much
shorter one for two weeks on algorithmic
fairness and today we have with us in
which was Ronnie the IROC live in
Cynthia Ward right thank you very much
rich guy and Cynthia for coming for an
interview to find out what clusters were
about and more importantly what your
fields are but what is about the
computation about today was the are the
most important questions and similarly
for algorithmic fairness and I think
I'll start with emissions that from lift
will randomize the order but highly and
I we all know that the topic of quantum
computation has been taking more and
more center stage there's very
interesting efforts and universities and
research laboratories and in countries
toward building a quantum computer and
in recent years there's been success
actually in being able to utilize more
and more quantities in controlled
fashion and my question to you is what
is the role of computer science in just
and please yeah that's that's a great
question
actually in in in a certain sense you
know this recent success on the
experimental side and in computing it's
you know which is which is you know that
that's that's come about both in
industry and in academia and and with
with a great deal of effort and
ingenuity on the part of experiment is
you know in terms of pushing the
boundaries but but together with that
the what's become clear is that that
that the major challenge moving forward
is this algorithmic so how what are we
going to do with these near-term quantum
computers once they're built and how we
be even test that they are quantum so it
it it turns out that you know this is
sort of a widely acknowledged at this
point you know it's an increasingly and
widely acknowledged challenge which is
how do we get computers you know
computer scientists engaged in this
enterprise on a much larger scale and
that was one of the one of the issues
that we had in mind in running the
seventh master wishes to actually focus
in on these algorithmic challenges and
and in order to focus it you know in
order to understand these challenges
actually you have to have a deep
engagement between computer scientists
and all the chemists and physicists and
it's the sort of engagement that you
cannot carry out you cannot ask the
computer scientists to go to physics
conferences of chemistry conferences
because that's that just would not be
you know a place where you can actually
understand the computational issues and
so you know this is where the Simon's
Institute really occupies a unique place
where it provides this kind of
playground where we can actually have
this engagement at a deep
between chemists physicists and computer
scientists in a in you know while while
actually focusing much more on the
computational side and the algorithmic
side of these of these points so it's
very interesting what you're saying so
you're saying there are these
large-scale efforts in fact they involve
many people in a lot of fun funding to
build these computers but we don't
really know yet what to do with them
even and once they would be built and
this is a place where algorithm
designers computer scientists have a
crucial role to play that's right so you
know in the the issue that that comes up
in the near term is so so we we have a
much better understanding of what you
could do in the long term with quantum
computers but but in the near term
quantum computers are going to be much
more noisy and they'll they'll be
smaller scale and and in that regime we
have much less understanding of the
algorithmic capabilities of these
computers so you know in a in a sense
what's what's happened now is we you
know we should we should sort of
contrast or and compare where we are
today to the very early days of quantum
computing which which you know just
about 25 years ago when when the early
steps in quantum computing were taken
you know through quantum complexity
theory and quantum algorithm so computer
scientists sort of developed and
understood that this was a this was a
wonderful new field and then there was
you know there was this challenge of
bringing the physicists up to speed on
the subject and in fact what happened is
that over a sequence of years we had we
had me summer workshops at and there's a
quality know in
in Torino in Italy so this was a this
was a villa you know on the top of the
top of the hill in in Torino it was it
was devoted to you know to a family you
know it was there was a foundation of
the
Institute for scientific interchange
which which wanted to promote new
science and and basically it was a place
where computer scientists and physicists
hung out together for about six weeks
every summer and and over the course of
this you know these interactions may
develop the language of quantum
computing it was a it was a really
exciting time you know it was it was it
was a clear round you know to to develop
this sort of interdisciplinary you know
collaboration and in a sense you know
where we are today is an echo of where
we were 25 years ago except now this
time what we are trying to do is you
know now the the experimental physicists
have have managed to reach much father
you know make a lot of progress in terms
of where they are and but but now now we
have completely new algorithmic
challenges and in order to even
understand what those challenges are and
to to in order to sort of abstract out
and the correct questions and and and
you know the correct paradigms we really
have to have a have an interaction you
know at at a deep level and and once you
you know the the the most interesting
thing is when when you are in this kind
of interdisciplinary sort of regime
reading up reading papers by by by the
other group this is not really practical
it takes you know it takes a very long
time it's very hard to interpret close
papers and it's much easier if you set
up the the right kind of workshops you
know with the right format so that you
you you know so that so that you
actually make sure that discussion is is
given primacy over just presentation and
so this is what we really try to do in
this in this six-week in this eight-week
program so we had and and it was you
know it was a stimulating invasive a
successful it's one of the things you've
brought up is that there are new
algorithmic challenges and the more they
gather gather one of the unwritten
challenges how do you verify actually
we've actually knew first point that's
what how do you verify that the quantum
computer is actually doing something
beyond the classical computer yeah if
the content yes yeah that's you know
it's it's a it's sort of a unique
challenge in the sense that a quantum
computer is at the same time an
incredibly powerful object you know in
the in the sense that it can it can
compute exponentially faster or you know
do computations which are which are
prohibitively not costly it also covers
its tracks extremely well so you know in
other words if you try to peek inside a
quantum computer its bottom state
collapses and and all you see is a small
classical state so it's very hard to
check something if if it keeps covering
its its tracks know you know and and and
the covering of of the tracks is is
really a part of the axioms of quantum
mechanics so it's it's built into
quantum mechanics and so you know and so
one of the recent breakthroughs is is is
understanding how to unity is you know
to to think about
to think about this this quantum
computer as something whose power we can
limit by using cryptography and this is
a very interesting interesting notion
that you know to say well even though
this quantum computer is extremely
powerful there are certain things it
cannot do well you know and these these
involve certain you know that there are
certain classical tasks which which even
a quantum computer cannot cannot perform
and then how can we use these classical
tasks as leverage to check that the
quantum computer is doing what it's
supposed to be doing and so you know if
this there's this is this real you know
interesting leverage that you get by by
taking something it can't do to check
that the it's doing everything else it's
supposed to be doing so the prices are
coming from the point of view of some
thinking about it so you had ins to
paraphrase we're thinking here or proof
is an adversarial process so there is
this quantum computer that's or someone
who does the con computer it claims that
there are certain computations that have
been done and you're suspect it's just
so this close yeah and any proof is in
some sense verifying some suspicious
claim and how do you verify this
suspicious claim so you're sort of Ewing
the Claver as an adversary and you say
well he's an adversary there certain
things this episode can't do and if I
somehow combine the challenges of what
he claims to do with the challenges
which you can't do in such a way that he
can only answer truthfully because
otherwise it would solve this difficult
challenge yes I assume that that's
somebody s and and so that that's
exactly right it's and and you know in
that sense you know this is testing of
quantum
quantum computers actually ties up
innovative way to both cryptography and
complexity theory where where these
interactive proof systems where Europe
where you're interacting with them with
a powerful prover and you know in
complexity theory that powerful prover
is a mythical power to approve of it but
in quantum computer computation this
this powerful proven SEO is it one
computer so it's it's really you know at
the same time it's it's it's a very deep
connection but it's it's it's also a big
practical connection as us as we are
discovering and so this is another sense
in which in which you know the science
Institute is really acting as a
playground where the quantum computation
is you know is interacting with
cryptography and complexity theory more
more classical complexity theory in
classical cryptography in you know again
to to bring people together where they
don't have to necessarily learn
everything about the other fields worth
while getting you know wild technique
some of it some of these in central
questions so in fact I think that you in
this workshop that you've on you
remember workshop as part of your
cluster there were a lot of computer
cryptographers who participated and they
were extremely excited they're saying is
this exciting things happening Quantic
appears when they're using cryptography
and we now want to learn much more about
what the computers than ever before
because you can see that they're born
you miss bingum's
yes so you know that i should focus on
to to toxin in particular they were
there was a there was a talk by Jana
where she may she spoke about how some
concepts from quantum computing no
signaling were used in in cryptography
and then there was a there was a talk by
now instrument or Mohammed II we spoke
about how how post quantum cryptography
you know
concepts from cryptography but he was to
test on the computers and it was it was
really an exciting session and there was
one where you know as you as you said
there was there was a great deal of
excitement on the part of photographers
to learn about these connections but
typically using I think the learning
with error problem which is right now
hard quantum resilient as the basis is
this hard computational problem then we
assume the quantum computers can solve
and will and this work that you referred
to of your student she leverages this
impossibility in order to verify
yes
it's really beautiful work and it's
really exciting
yeah well I want to learn more as a
photographer and I I agree with you that
I think that part of the mission of the
Science Institute is to enable this kind
of collaboration between people from
other disciplines but even within third
of computer science you know people work
on quantum computer Universal
photographer versus complexity to
establish a common language and also to
realize that there that we need these
common skills in order to make
meaningful contributions
yeah the the you know the what one of
the ways I think about it is that you
know that if but I usually think of this
as viscosity you know when each of our
fields has has some you know if you try
to understand something in a neighboring
field and you try to you know you try to
read the papers it's just so viscous
it's so hard to move through them and
you know whereas if you if you have the
people who wrote those papers next to
you you you you know the the actual
ideas and concepts are so much easier
than then what actually gets conveyed
through the papers and and so you know
it takes a place like this that like the
sciences to do you know one could
imagine that
that it really speeds up the process of
scientific discovery by all those
magnitude of to me because it's just so
much faster and so much more efficient
thank you wish now when I turn to the
fairness cluster so it's all the rage I
mean it's kind of amazing how quickly
this idea of using algorithms in terms
of for sometimes people think that it's
just machine learning but algorithms to
make decisions that do ously were made
by humans people people who have been
trained to do so in the tradition system
policing in many other areas of life
there's discussion about replacing
existing mechanisms by algorithms and I
understand that the important question
is how you ensure that these algorithms
work in a fair manner but I have a much
lesser understanding what he means to be
fair and I think that you know this
question is a difficult question what
does it mean to be fair and my first
question is sort of what how do you see
the role of algorithmic fairness in the
context of computer science or what is
always a very great Tomcat so the air
quotes let you put any word very apt
because in many ways we really don't
know so you mentioned many areas in
which algorithms are starting to make
decisions that previously have been made
by humans and by trained humans but one
area in which algorithms have been
making decisions all along has been
online advertising and so when we
started the eve of this work back in
2010 then there were already plenty of
online systems and AD platforms that
were doing exactly this so
The Wall Street Journal actually ran a
really interesting series of articles
called what they know which was mostly
about privacy but they did raise a
particular scenario so at the time that
the article was written with me in
August of 2010 if you went to a bank
website before the bank would actually
show you anything it would consult with
a tracking network and the tracking
network would already have placed you
into some tens or dozens of of
demographic bins and based on your PIN
and only on your bin you would be
showing a certain that and so the
concern that was raised in that article
was the worry about the illegal practice
of steering minorities to credit card
offerings of less desirable terms so the
credit industry is more tightly
regulated than other industry it's many
other industries in this country and
even in the advertisements in the online
world their regulations not relevant so
in that sort of a setting you kind of
imagine that you have a population your
population has various demographic
minorities you could be racial
minorities gender preference minorities
medical minorities people with various
sorts of disabilities religious
minorities political minorities and so
on and and so you might be thinking in
terms of somehow trying to find notions
of fairness that treated groups the same
way and when we started working on this
we you know started in that general
approach but we also having some
background in cryptography started
thinking as you said we were thinking
about adversarial advertisers what would
they want
we started listing all the
goals of the adversary and then when we
thought about very natural notions of
fairness we realized that they wouldn't
defeat some of these adversarial
adversaries adversarial goals and so so
we knew that we suspected that group
notions were just not good solution
concepts for fairness and started
turning to a notion of individual
fairness of individual fairness would
say roughly speaking that if two people
are very similar for a specific
classification task than they ought to
be treated similarly and so this is
really the time to in classification
tasks for each conservation test it
could be six defensible addressing
exactly you and I might be very similar
for some things and completely different
courts a movie recommendations or
whatever so that's what it brings up the
general paradigm that you know you
pioneer which is what you're trying to
handle and a big question you have to
first of all define what are the goals
of the adversary and therefore what does
it mean to get it right and then once
you've got some definitions you trying
to find some algorithms that satisfy
these definitions and finally because as
we see people are classified over and
over and over again and many different
contexts we want to understand something
about how things behave like a
composition and so that's a general
framework for trying to to make some
progress here as we've been discussing
the definitions are difficult and they
provide they present challenges that I
haven't seen before in cryptography
privacy just completely different sorts
of challenges and one of the reasons is
that fairness is fundamentally
it's it's a question of sort of human
and emotional perception and the process
of arriving at something that's
considered fair is a fundamentally
political process but you know
politicians can say things that are sort
of stupid and then have silly
consequences so computers are better if
the computer science has a real role
here in sort of saying what do you mean
by fairness if you're going to legislate
some sort of fairness what does it mean
and what are the consequences of
anything that you might say so we have
these groups various definitions which
we don't like for the reasons we
described we have these individual
fairness definitions which are really
nice and have really pleasing math but
this notion of how similar or dissimilar
people are for a particular
classification task where's that metric
company we don't know we don't have
finder so now there's some movement to
finding definitions that kind of bridge
these two general principles so I know
that one of the definitions that it's
more cependant to me is this idea that
maybe you can't define what courtesies
but what's behind it is what when people
say something's not fair it's not
because you know when they did they like
to complain over this itself hardly cold
but but it's because they want to change
the outcome so rather than actually
define in fairness you want to make it
such that you could change the Welcome
right and that's a that's a very
interesting wait they don't have that
you are working on now in to come up
with a definition and just going back to
Caracas and soon related to we were non
malleable story knocked in some cases
malleability there might be a good thing
exactly it's exactly the opposite but my
liability is station can you it's not so
much can you learn about
message from its encryption but can you
essentially come up with another
encryption whose underlying message is
related to something that was sensitive
so here you actually want things to be
malleable in some sense right you might
so if somebody is say applying for a
loan and they're turned down
when they say why was I turned down you
might think that the real question is
what can I do at reasonable cost that
will get to a different outcome get to
the other outcome so we're we're calling
this concept negotiability for now and
there are all sorts of really natural
questions and you can you can sort of
start going into the cryptographic
framework and obfuscation and blah blah
blah but the osha bility it seems really
appealing of course there are worries
about if you have a negotiable
classifier and gamer ball and how do you
mean sure that that's not what's going
on
also there seem to be some kinds of
connections to kind of the adversarial
learning we're adding a little bit of
noise can't completely change the
classification and it's a bad thing
there but it might be good here right
it's exactly opposing goals seeing
exactly that which is how to make sure
that it's not right and then there's
other work done recently on explanation
so you have a machine learning system
that same reads an x-ray and decides
that something is
it's cancer and provides an explanation
which is pointing to a certain
collection of pixels and saying because
of these pixels and it turns out that
you can just return the image a bit and
keep the same classification but the
explanation turns out to be completely
broke and so for us that would
correspond to saying well here are the
difference things that you could do to
come to a different in our case it's not
that it's not a bad thing but anyway
we're trying to understand how all of
these things are connected to each other
do you think I mentioned the question of
composition that part of the challenge
is that you want to be able to compose
different fairness you know and how do
you do it if you use different
initiatives to be being members of
different groups and I don't think you
have some work on composition maybe one
tell us a little bit about that so what
want to speak about that and I generally
want to speak about what we as computer
scientists can bring to the table
talking about fairness and you should
say that fairness really is a said it's
a big question it's multidisciplinary
it's been social sciences economics
ethics law and when we as computer
science come to talk about fairness we
of course are ambitious and we want to
solve as much of it as we can but we
know that it's a big problem and we try
to tackle it as computer scientists to
abstract it to the best of our ability
and to tackle pieces of it and you know
Cynthia was speaking about the great
difficulty of arriving at a single sort
of all spanning definition of fairness
that's a real difficulty and part of the
work we've been doing or the community
has been engaged in is getting they're
proposing different notions of fairness
and coming from the cryptographic
background also trying to define
particular concerns about fairness so it
might be very difficult to define in a
single concise way what fairness is and
but it might also be much easier to
define various notions of unfairness
that's think it was mentioning that you
did in her early work and so as
photographers one thing that we could
think of is trying to model different
fairness concerns and maybe fight you
know you know proposed a method for
fighting the capacitance or one in
fairness with some to fares than certain
three and hopefully this sort of is a
path towards progress maybe at the end
of the day will reach a single all
spanning definition of fairness and show
how to guarantee it
maybe will he'll have the sort of quiver
full of arrows that we can use to combat
different types of discrimination and so
along these lines most one work that
I've been engaged in recently again
thinking about fairness from computer
science perspective you know one thing
we could try to do is to combat all the
ills of that already exist in the world
but another is trying to identify well
what kinds of unfairness is might
computer science itself be generating
and how can we fight those this isn't a
new concern if it's been receiving a lot
of popular attention
but if we use algorithms to make
decisions the decisions might be biased
because the algorithms are trained on is
data and that's bad but another concern
is even if the data themselves aren't
biased the algorithms could be
introducing bias and discrimination
for example because classifying a
certain minority is computationally
expensive yes may be the minority
finding say qualified loan applicants in
a minority there are plenty of them but
they look different from the ones in the
majority and the algorithm we just let
it unleash it into the wild that it's
run on its own let it run on its own
would optimize really well I'm part of
the population and ignore the other part
so this is a discrimination that isn't
in the data but assertive in could do
introduced because of computational
considerations and that may well be
something we want to fight and so we
have definitions talking about we call
this multi calibration sort of ensuring
that the algorithm does pay attention to
all of the different subpopulations that
might be present whether it's minorities
whether we're talking about different
types of minorities
and intersectionality and I sort of use
the power of computer science to combat
this concern so computer science to fix
it and really make sure that the
algorithm is paying attention to all of
the different populations that it should
be anymore so that's work that happened
in the past one of the things we've been
engaged in over the summer that I think
is very exciting is taking this line of
work and together with engaging us with
Cynthia taking this line of work and
applying it not only to making sure that
the data about all the different
populations is represented in the result
but also using these insights moving
them forward to doing some sort of
affirmative action
so correcting for biases that are on the
data not just representing truth as it
is in the data but hopefully
representing sort of truthful truth as
we would want it to be
so instead you're saying on one hand we
want to make sure they were not to be
harmed by using algorithms but we can
actually use own with them to detect
biases that exist and they're kind of
given it's one thing to talk about bias
but we can do supported because we can
show algorithmically outcomes that are
in some sense of comfort in fact there
is wise not existing and then we can use
algorithmic techniques to correct for it
too so I questioned about how I know you
had a very small cluster and the hope is
to have a larger one in the future it
was two weeks right it was tunes what
was it like it was now here it was two
weeks it was fabulous it was very very
intense and there's been a real
explosion of research in theoretical
computer science community and also in
the machine learning
tips on my CML kind of song fairness
unaware of my fairness and even in the
last two or three years tremendous
number of paper so we have a number of
people who have been doing some of this
work together to sort of like what you
were saying everybody could read each
other's papers but a lot of headway with
me when we could just really stop people
and say let's maybe this point it's like
at this point we made a lot of progress
it's pretty and and and really developed
it then several new lines of research
and this was only in two weeks it's
taking a lot of time just to sort of
process what what we experienced
absolutely so many things came out of it
and one of the really really nice
offices we had a talk from Lucia Jacobs
who's in the psychology department at
Berkeley Network can you give us a talk
on the Anthropology fairness and that
was it was absolutely fascinating
it was objectively fascinating but it
also suggested that there might be some
very few principles on which at least
anthropologically fairness seem to be
based it doesn't mean that it's rightful
what we're doing now in the online world
and so on but it was it was very
suggestive this way Lucia will be
visiting Radcliffe as a Radcliffe fellow
next week Spira
she and I already have some experiments
for involving squirrels can you tell us
like he had to take one not become then
you have a topological fairness what
would you say where I mean I think some
people would say that the life is not
fair
growing up with a Jewish family but in
that you just have to deal with it but
what is something that we think
evolutionary an example
thing that surprised me that she
mentioned that I hadn't bought great
so she was [ __ ] help the size of food
packets so if you managed to get a small
rabbit that's a small food packet if you
managed to kill an elephant that's a
very large food packet and she talked
about things like that the cost of
defending a large food packet
once you have eaten enough this too high
and so you share it but you also get
status by sharing and so the talk was
filled with these these little nuggets
like that and I don't know I think you
had some some take-home messages you
remember I do so one thing was certainly
there Cindy was saying there are these
simple facts or principles about the
environment that really affects people's
perceptions of fairness so for example
in a society where food is scarce
perhaps people are less willing to share
as Cynthia was saying in society where
food packets are very large for example
there was one example of villagers
islands in Indonesia that hunt whales so
the hunting is a collaborative effort
for the body by its very nature it's
great for one person to bring down the
whale and you've been a club person
brings down a whale something really
would do with the whales so there's a
seem to be very evolved protocols for
you know how long shares and spoils what
you know what rewards each person who
did a certain test gets after the whale
is brought down and then their
experiments of how these people feel
about helping you know people in this
sort of environment feel about certain
divisions of goods or certain offers and
ways of dividing goods what is fair and
what isn't fair and it's very different
from environments where food is scarce
or it's every man every person for
themselves it's a simple example of how
the environment can really affect a
community's perception of fairness so it
would be wonderful if there were simple
principles
that one could derive to finish your
penance so in physics right so that sort
of laws of families and they don't
involve you know the more chill is up
something goes up then something else
goes down that's always worth
fascinating about physical things so
simple rules and they're not an
elaborate definitions so that's one of
the thoughts that may be individual
fairness that similar should be treated
similarly would be such an example and
there's a really famous video that you
can find on youtube of a pair of
capuchin monkeys and an experiment the
monkeys have to carry out a task in this
case it's to handle rock to the
experimenters and the monkeys are
rewarded with some food so in its
experiment got a pair of monkeys and the
first monkey hands the rock over and
gets a slice of cucumber and is
perfectly happy with the cucumber the
second monkey does the same task and get
some grape and then the first monkey
does the task again and get two cucumber
but the first time she has seen the
grape and seeing the other one get agree
and when it gets to cucumber it goes
ballistic and first it just throws it
back at the experimenter and then it
sticks its arm out of the cage and so
it's pounding the table and it jumps up
and down and so on it just it doesn't
want to cucumber when the other one got
a grape because what is up with the
other one Cup but that's what I took
from it but actually I'm not sure and
here's the question that I have in that
Lucian I want to experiment with suppose
you started with feeding this month one
month just
give it a cucumber and then the next
time you reward it same one with a grape
and then the third time you reward it
with a cucumber is it going to say wait
I want agree.i grapes aren't possible
and maybe that's what it learned by
seeing its friend to get a grape then
it's just eight grapes are possible and
to help with this cucumber nonsense so I
don't know I don't know whether it's the
failure of an anticipated reward which
is something that we should mentioned in
a totally different context or whether
it's the neighbor about the grape so I
want to find out I'll add to that that
it might not be that we can find simple
rules that apply to everyone but one
thing that was suggested by this talk is
that maybe fairness really no there is
no single answer for fairness but the
complexity of the different answers that
we might have isn't so great it's
affected by a few variables things like
the packet size or scarcity of food in
the environment so it's not this huge
intractable problem but rather we can
simplify it into a few different types
of fairness preferences that people have
and then going back to questions about
composition how do we make sure everyone
is happy and everyone is getting things
that they think are fair what different
people is very might be different so you
were brought into that pub to talk in
general I think that social scientists
and so forth and apologists in this case
lawyers and thought about these
questions of fairness and all of a
sudden we arrive on the scene
these computer scientist and one may
saying that maybe we are presumptuous in
thinking that we can advance the field I
personally don't believe it but I was
wondering what you thought out of that
so no I don't think that we're
presumptuous I think that we have we're
going to have machines making decisions
we have to understand how to instruct
them and
the lawyers and ethicists don't know how
but the thing is that you can go back to
questions in say US law unfairness and
sorry I'm forgetting a term it's a term
involving a puppeteer
disparate impact okay so you go on and
look at questions and disparate impact
and when you examine them carefully in
the context of machine learning you can
see that some of the tests in American
law don't make as much sense anymore
so I've been working on developing a
project for a bunch of undergraduates to
look at this but I'm working with a
graduate student at Harvard in the
government department and he had a lot
of insights into how computer science
will actually change some basic
considerations and that previously looks
yeah what was going on the disparate
impact case don't actually make sense
anymore thank you very much for coming
to Simon's for these incredible
interview thanks mom thank you thank you